boy the boat dodgy
my name is Josh salt I am partner
development manager Google Play and I
manage kids apps and games so today I'll
be talking about optimizing for a post
install world namely how do you retain
and engage families in your ecosystem so
you've spent a lot of time effort
resources getting a user to ultimately
download your app right it's quite the
process there's motivation discovery
expectation search filter and then
finally the download so what about after
the download so let's look at the user
funnel we go have the view listing
install open the app today I really want
to focus on the bottom to engaging with
your app and retention I have a number
of different case studies partners have
been willing to share with us and
hopefully some great facts and data that
you'll find interesting for your
businesses so since acquisition costs
are high it's really important to engage
your most loyal users optimising the
lifetime value of your traffic is key
for acquisition campaigns and making it
most cost effective so this is a pretty
staggering stat 50 to 90 percent of app
users have turned after just 30 days so
just let that sink in for a moment no
matter how great your app is that's just
how it is and that's really the struggle
that a lot of developers find and you
know lays the groundwork for what we're
going to talk about today so what are
some of the key reasons for churn first
of all there's poor technical quality
another one is inefficient or unclear
value proposition thirdly outdated
content or
shonali not personalized and also too
many push notifications all of these can
cause major headaches for your business
and we're going to address them today so
the format of this presentation is
really threefold going to start off by
talking about user onboarding we
actually just had a great presentation
from zero one digital they talked about
how they're thinking through onboarding
and we have some great data from budge
studios as well second of all we're
going to talk about successfully
releasing new features and content how
PBS KIDS is thinking through that and
other partners and then finally we're
going to talk about re-engaging users so
to start off how to make user onboarding
great and thank you again for your
presentation so now that you've had a
user download your title it's time to
make sure they keep using it and
thinking through tutorial and
registration is key on the tutorial side
focus on the value and make it fun and
simple also allow users to skip the demo
and see it later as an option and be
sure to explain ancillary features and
make sure it's relevant to the user and
focus on your top metric and then this
will be a common theme through today is
just really testing testing testing and
iterate for your best D 1 and D 7
retention on the registration side be
sure that you show value for the
information asked so what does the user
get and don't bar access and optimize
your onboarding value proposition so you
really have to focus on getting your
user to engage with your app in an
instant it's a very competitive world
out there as we know we're just talking
about how much competition there is in
the market so you really have to
differentiate yourself that way so
familiarize new users with your app by
designing a simple and easy onboarding
process make it fast and seamless
contextual and part of the product
experience
also ask for minimal input while
gathering the information you need to
create engagement so one great example
is a developer out of Montreal Canada
called budge studios budge Studios has
created their own IP and they're also
licensing such prominent IP as Hello
Kitty and Caillou as well as Thomas the
Train so a few of the things that budge
Studios thinks through one is fast time
to fund really how do you get someone
into the app quickly how do you get them
having fun right away the first playable
moment is really critical here and early
wins to build the users confidence is
key we'll touch about this later as well
so be sure to cut the unnecessary steps
to your process and for effective
onboarding you also need to check for
drop-offs so in terms of budge Studios
they want to get players in the game
faster and be wary of drop-off and
really one key metric here is to find
the right value for first time user
experience and this actually was not the
case originally with Miss Hollywood they
found that it was too hard this title
for preschoolers so by making the
first-time experience easier they
actually increased their first time
retention by 11 percent that 11 percent
actually accounts for millions of
additional minutes of play and test test
test like we were saying you got to keep
testing budge studios through their
rigorous testing was able to find that
initial game loop included five
characters one of which had issues with
their microphone permissions so after
adjusting this permission and fixing it
they saw an increase of to 74 percent of
first-time users in this loop compared
to 25 percent in the previous loop and
we had the honor of having play kids
present here earlier today there another
great example in terms of focusing on
user
boarding and they spent a lot of time
running tests to update their onboarding
value proposition so here you have the
old onboarding and then the new one that
they rolled out the new version actually
took their conversion rate from point
four all the way up to above point seven
percent and this pop up that you see
which really laid out their value
proposition in a more clear fashion that
increased their sales by 81 percent so
81 percent increase in sales by just
improving your pop up is a pretty
staggering number so in terms of
onboarding you can test using onboarding
flows with firebase remote config you
can run a B test experiments or change
app behavior control custom key value
pairs from the console and make changes
that are instant another key factor that
not everyone is really taking advantage
of our avatars I love this quote from
play science says when children were
asked to design their own app the
feature that they listed is the most
important was the ability to create
their own avatar yet few of the top
playful games offer this unique feature
suggesting a great opportunity for
developers and here I'd like to point to
roblox another prominent developer based
in the u.s. they have been really
focused on their avatar and as soon as a
user interacts with their app they give
them control to customize it so what
have been the results well this is
pretty staggering once again 60% of new
signups customize their avatar and out
of that 60% they're seeing that the
retention rate is 1.8 times better
almost 2x the other user group next I
would like to talk about how to engage
in retain families through successfully
releasing new features and content once
again roblox is a great example here
they have a systematic release
methodology they test it with beta users
to make
ensure that you're really getting out
there testing it with the right user
community that's appropriate for your
ages right makes making sure it's
technically stable show what's new and
lastly analyze that performance PBS KIDS
is really a great example of a developer
out there who's refreshing content and
updating it on a regular basis they add
new games weekly they have seasonal
updates around big moments Halloween
Christmas here can be give kids a number
of other moments and be sure to update
around that and be sure to update your
icons we saw some of the results that
play kids had in terms of updating their
their icons and that's low hanging fruit
if you can improve your conversion rate
78% like they are saying that's pretty
tremendous and not a tremendous amount
of work so the key question is is there
enough value in your app I wanted to
point to this example budge studios this
is a graph that showed retention the top
number is when they gave away three free
items and the bottom is when they gave
away two so as you can see that that
really spiked their numbers this isn't
necessarily what a lot of developers
think there's usually the perception
that you have to limit a lot of the free
content but we're actually finding
otherwise and this is some great data
from budge studios that the first time
experience was better and that actually
led to greater retention engagement and
ultimately revenue by actually giving
away that third character the third part
I'd like to talk about is reengage in
users and leveraging your key channels
so be sure to ensure that all your
organic channels are being clearly
marketed using Android and update your
existing channels including email
website social and YouTube
here we have some examples from roblox
they have an inbox in their app and so
they're able to push notifications
directly to the user some other examples
include what they're doing on social
media and YouTube a lot of developers
aren't really leveraging the about page
on their YouTube pitch so that about
page is a great place to link to your
Google Play listing you can also link to
your website social media accounts it's
easy and we've seen some strong results
out of that roblox is also using social
media as I mentioned before form a
Facebook Twitter and they're also doing
YouTube cards YouTube cards can pop up
on the side of your videos if you're
running different videos on YouTube
those are free to use and another great
way to reengage users bring them back to
your store listing page on google play
toca Boca also provides a great example
of how a top premium developer is
leveraging their ecosystem to really
push new titles out and a great example
of that is their toca life series they
have a number of different toca life
apps including toca life town toca life
vacation and they actually just released
toca life farm which is a when our top
premium titles currently on Google Play
so toca life is a series of apps that
gives kids access to role-playing
universe filled with everyday fun it's
uniquely created for kids and it's was
really a direct result of communicating
with that their fan base and taking user
feedback so since the release of the
first app in May 2014 toca Boca has
received more than 60,000 feature
requests and reviews from kids all over
the world and its feedback that has
informed their toca life series and has
brought us these titles
and this this title toka life vacation
was their most successful launch ever
and it's really because they leverage
their previous ecosystem so 32 percent
of users downloading toka life vacation
had downloaded one of the previous had
downloaded all of the previous three
apps and 38 percent of users downloading
toca life vacation had downloaded one or
two of those previous apps so be sure
that your cross-promotion is really on
point
once again test and make sure that it's
relevant and driving the the benefits
that you were you're going for you know
another one is using rich notifications
to bring users back to your app so a few
best practice here here is include
actual content deep linking to the right
part of your app stacking similar
notifications and void spamming and
testing so what what are the the things
to do with notifications
well one get users familiar to consider
reactivation 3 try to make an emotional
connection for include actual content 5
deep link and 6 really consider your
audience this is especially important
the kids in family space and then just
for things that you want to avoid and
not do with notifications or don't push
spam notifications don't forget to
expire notifications don't push ads
house ads are permitted though and don't
leave notifications up to guesswork so
the case study here that I wanted to
highlight on the notification and
messaging side is speaker boosts they
utilize a combination of notifications
emails push in social media to reinforce
a message that furthers their brand for
speaker boosts each touch point is
designed to motivate a love of reading
by connecting children to their
interests so speak speaker boost push
notification
this example it's fun is reverent they
said did you know it's world pasta day
so that really activated their user base
they also time it with new content
releases exclusive content holiday
events and discounts and they've seen
strong results from their push
notifications as well as from their
messaging they regularly test a B
results analyze those metrics and
optimize based on a variety of factors
and this is resulted in a nice uplift so
new story doy newt new story day for
speaker boosts email is an email that
promotes special and exclusive content
that has driven a 5% increase in click
rates and content that makes a use of
appropriate hashtags is another you know
key to this overall they've seen a 60
percent increase with web traffic when
it's paired with social accounts for 5
percent of monthly traffic so I hope
that was helpful I know we covered a lot
of things wanted to include a lot of
case studies and data from some of our
top partners hopefully in next
presentation next time we come down here
we'll include more data from a lot of
you guys we know this is collaborative
but just to reiterate the three key
things that we really encourage you to
think through our onboarding new
features and content releases and Riaan
gauging your users so thank you very
much